should be pretty easy walking is easy
we're humans my hearts were like bro
what are you doing I looked up how far
10,000 steps really is actually quite a
bit almost five miles it 10,000 is a
little daunting I do a lot of life
change type things and I don't really
commit and in the end I don't have any
results
walking seems easy like I can walk I
used to live in Chicago I used to walk
all the time when I was your age I
walked three miles to work in the snow
I'm sitting at my desk it gets really
hard to stay active and fit I don't have
the best sleep schedule exercise is
something that just goes out the window
I'm always telling me I gotta get
exercise I think it's time that I get
some exercise I feel like my body was
healthier when I walked a lot more
although I did eat a lot more frozen
pizzas if I missed 10,000 steps I owe
$10 I give that to chariot if I miss one
hundred thousand steps I own $100 I
don't plan on giving a lot of money to
charity for this maybe there will be a
day when I'm feeling generous and I will
want to do nothing
hmm except it dude all right I love it
how cute where does where do I put this
on my body
because it's crazy cold outside I am NOT
going out there and I'm doing steps
inside with these guys I've been sick
the last few days doesn't even matter
cuz I didn't have my Fitbit in my pocket
for the last five days I am walking at
work I decided to walk to lunch today
look at that we're gonna walk up we're
gonna get a lot of steps in help me come
on guys let's go
I am shocked by that but I'll take it
I'm at the bottom by slow the chance to
turn around I have good excuses why I
haven't hit those marks it's 40 degrees
outside and raining and it's been that
way all day hey can you realize you've
only been half the amount of steps
you're supposed to do and your bed is so
warm I don't know if that's gonna happen
it's really hard to go do it having the
dog is a great excuse because it gets me
up right away in the morning it forces
me to walk it really does on weekends
I'm just laying in my bed and it's like
I could just be walking I am walking in
neighborhood I feel better I would make
me feel like I'm actually doing
something
so guys who isn't here right now I'm
sleeping for a piece of [ __ ] so hard my
legs aren't like you jeez Keith my
hearts were like bro what are you doing
I want to blame the influenza virus
there was a day that I did wear the
Fitbit I walked a hundred steps being
the biggest loser also means that I'm
the biggest philanthropist yeah I'm
gonna give it to Alzheimer's that's a
good charity to give money to well no I
just was last before so I was kind of
anticipating being last I did a lot
better when I was back at work emailing
made me get up a lot I think I'm gonna
donate my money to a high school that's
in watt for the neighborhood boys then I
was in Chicago for like a week and a
half and it was freezing that entire
week it's just a walk I have 47 dollars
I think I'll give it a st. jude's the
Children's Hospital that's a safe bet
done ten thousand almost every day I
tried that's amazing that's the
difference if you try you'll almost make
it here so here you giving nine bucks
too I feel like giving them $9 to a joke
maybe just throw nine dollars on one of
our charities I think I'm gonna go with
sick little kids again that's the safe
bet I like feel like I probably will
it's slightly obsessive to the console I
know what number it is like a little
game you're playing everyday I think the
only thing that did slightly more this
is like always take the stairs and I was
at work doing a little bit of extra
effort you know the bare minimum extra
I'm doing that I'm definitely not gonna
feel bad if I don't hit 10,000 any more
I'm not gonna stress about it but all
these try
my life has changed